okay a very special piece of mail came
today it is my official ballot for the
2012 presidential election from Bucks
County I'm voting absentee in
Pennsylvania so I'm gonna vote here is
the official election ballot you can
vote party column which means everything
down in the Republican Democrat green or
Libertarian Party presidential Mitt
Romney Paul Ryan Barack Obama and Joe
Biden in the green and Libertarian Party
also have a state senator Auditor
General attorney general treasurer for
Pennsylvania Congress congressional
representative and a representative in
the General Assembly which is just the
Congress of Pennsylvania so I'm gonna
vote get my pin out here not gonna show
you who I'm voting for I know you
thought I was gonna do it when I'm not
gonna and then we're gonna deliver it to
the mailbox
okay the ballot is complete let's go
deliver it to the mailbox
alright the deed is done
I voted if you haven't voted yet you're
old enough to vote go out and get a
ballot if you're out of the state get an
absentee ballot and vote make sure you
vote I'm kind of sad I want to I don't
want to wait four years to do that again
whatever it was fun while it lasted